iran ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères qui va prononcer
l'allocution de la france
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale monsieur le secrétaire général
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement mesdames et messieurs
les chefs de délégations en nous
rappelant à quel point nos destins sont
liés pour le meilleur comme pour le pire
la crise pandémique nous a aussi rappelé
la valeur de ceux qui depuis plus de 75
ans nous rassemblent au sein de cette
organisation
le réflexe de la coopération le primat
du droit sur la force le respect
inconditionnel de la personne humaine
les principes de notre sharp n'ont rien
perdu de leur sens bien au contraire les
crises et les défis d'aujourd'hui leur
donne même une urgence nouvelle notre
sécurité notre santé notre planète sont
désormais des biens communs qui nous
revient de travailler à préserver
ensemble
cette impérative n'a rien d'une
abstraction rien d'un idéal c'est très
concrètement l'horizon de chacun de nos
choix est tout aussi concrètement la
sanction de chacune de nos divisions de
chacun de nos renoncements de chacune de
nos impuissances
car dans un monde d'échanger
d'interdépendance un monde en état
d'urgence environnementale un monde en
proie à de préoccupante logique de
brutalisation et à la tentation
persistante de l'unilatéralisme
tout ce que nous faisons collectivement
ou à linverse manquons de faire nous
engage tous devons en être conscients et
en tirer les conséquences ensemble
si on dépit des assauts qu'ils ont subis
ces dernières années les fondements du
système multilatéral en prouver leur
solidité trop de risques s'accumulent
qui ne sont pas maîtrisés et au nom de
la france est d'abord un message de
responsabilité que je souhaite porter
devant vous aujourd'hui
la première de nos responsabilités
partagées c'est le maintien de la paix
et de la sécurité internationales elles
sont en péril quand mes jeux de
puissance s'exacerbe quand les logique
de blogs réapparaissent quant au cadre
de régulation se défont quand des
tentatives du fait accompli se
multiplient c'est pourquoi la france
appelle de ses voeux la tenue d'un
sommet du p5 pour établir un programme
d'action commun afin de rendre au
conseil de sécurité la capacité
d'exercer tout son mandat et afin
d'engager le dialogue sur les sujets clé
du contrôle des armements et notre
sécurité collective et c'est pourquoi
nous agissons et continueront d'agir en
faveur de la paix de la stabilité dans
l'espace indo pacifique avec nos
partenaires de bonne volonté dans cette
région et avec d autres européens à nos
côtés la france en tant que nation de
l'inde au pacifique il ya des intérêts
majeurs tout comme l'europe qui vient de
se doter d'une stratégie en la matière
la paix et la sécurité internationales
se trouve aussi directement mis en jeu à
chaque fois qu'une crise éclate ou
franchir un nouveau seuil
en afghanistan notre devoir est
d'apporter à la population l'aide
humanitaire dont elle a besoin et notre
intérêt commun et de porter une exigence
politique et sécuritaire clair à l'égard
du régime de kaboul tout lien avec des
organisations terroristes doit être
rompu
vingt ans après le choc du 11 septembre
nous savons ce que la reconstitution
d'un sanctuaire terroriste impliquerait
pour nous tous
au levant et au sahel pour la même
raison nous devons poursuivre le combat
contre la menace terroriste
agir pour rétablir le dialogue la houle
est rompu et redonner des perspectives
d'avenir aux populations à travers les
combats de la stabilisation et du
développement
le président la république emmanuel
macron s'est rendu récemment à bagdad
afin d'y soutenir les efforts déterminés
des irakiens pour se rassembler et
rétablir la souveraineté
au sahel nous adoptons notre dispositif
militaire pour rester en mesure d'agir
dans la durée de répondre aux attentes
de nos partenaires régionaux et demeurer
pleinement disponible pour nos
partenaires internationaux ceux de la
coalition internationale pour le sahel
et ceux qui servent au sein de la minus
ma c'était fort
qui se traduit par de réels résultats je
veux pour preuve la neutralisation
récente d'abord lydall sahraoui cet
effort ne sera toutefois pas durable
sans stabilité politique et sans le
respect du chemin démocratique je pense
notamment au respect du calendrier fixé
pour l'organisation des élections au
mali qu'il est impératif de respecter
en libye une voix crédible existe
désormais pour rétablir l'unité et la
souveraineté du pays pourvu que chacun
se conforme à ses obligations que les
mercenaires étrangers se retirent que le
cessez-le-feu perdure et que des
élections se tiennent comme prévu c'est
à dire le 24 décembre prochain la france
souhaite que le conseil de sécurité les
voisins de la libye ce qui exerce une
influence agissent ensemble pour
atteindre notre objectif commun d'aller
au bout de la transition en cours c'est
le sens la conférence internationale de
soutien au processus politique et au
rétablissement la souveraineté libyenne
que nous organiserons à paris le 12
novembre prochain au proche-orient
divisée
le long de la ligne de contact en
ukraine ou encore dans le haut karabagh
et dans le sud caucase où le risque de
la conflictualité n'est toujours pas
écartée nous devons prévenir les
tensions défendent le droit
international et apporter un soutien
collectif à la mise en oeuvre de
solutions politiques concrètes quant à
la poursuite du programme nucléaire
iranien elle exige de nous la plus
grande fermeté l'iran ne peut croire que
le temps joue en sa faveur car les
risques d'une crise majeure augmente à
mesure que son programme nucléaire
devient plus dangereux les positions
américaines d'hier ne peuvent justifier
que l'iran continue de violer les
engagements qu'il a pris au titre du jcp
haut à la france prendra tous les
initiatives utiles au dialogue mais le
seul chemin possible demeure celui d'un
accord permettant d'établir que l'iran
respecte à nouveau ses obligations il
est donc indispensable que la
négociation reprenne très rapidement
les violations du droit international
humanitaire constitue enfin une grave
menace pour la paix et la sécurité
internationales en particulier lorsque
des personnels humanitaires et médicaux
sont pris pour cible alors même qu'ils
portent secours aux populations nous
devons donc nous donner les moyens de
mieux prévenir ces crimes et de punir
ceux qui s'en rendent coupables en syrie
au yémen au niger en rca en ethiopie ou
ailleurs notre responsabilité mesdames
et messieurs c'est aussi de construire
des réponses pragmatiques et solidaire
aux grands défis globaux qui engagent
notre avenir commun à commencer par le
défi du coc u19 qui n'est pas derrière
nous soyons très clairs la santé des
seins dépend de la santé de tous nous
devons donc poursuivre les efforts qui
grâce à l'initiative acta ont déjà
permis à 141 pays de recevoir
255 millions de doses de vaccins il
n'est pas possible que nous laissions se
creuser encore la fracture vaccinale qui
existe aujourd'hui entre le nord et le
sud parce que le sens et la crédibilité
même du multilatéralisme sont en jeu
dans cette épreuve parce que nous savons
que l'immunité sera globale ou ne sera
pas il est donc urgent d'obtenir une
accélération des livraisons de nous
assurer que chaque vaccins livrés soit
bien administrer et de renforcer nos
capacités de production sur tous les
continents la france continuera de
travailler en étroite concertation avec
ses partenaires notamment ceux du
continent africain notre engagement
donné 60 millions de do sera tenue d'ici
la fin de l'année et nous sommes fiers
de contribuer à financer un projet de
transfert de technologie en afrique du
sud qui devra permettre de développer
sur le continent des capacités autonomes
de production de vaccins arn messagers
la solidarité internationale doit aussi
prévaloir face à l'autre défi de la
crise pandémique le défi de la relance
économique
l'initiative de suspension la dette que
nous avons prises au g20 puis
l'établissement d'un cadre commun pour
son traitement ont d'ores et déjà permis
d'apporter une réponse à l'urgence mais
il faut aller plus loin en construisant
avec l'afrique le nouveau pacte que le
président macron a appelé de ses voeux
au sommet sur le financement des
économies africaines en mai dernier le
g20 doit s'engager pour que la location
des droits de tirage spéciaux que nous
avons décidé au fmi soit rapidement
complété par la réallocation d'une
partie d'entre eux aux pays qui en ont
le plus besoin la france est prête à
transférer 20 pour de son allocation de
dts vers les économies africaines afin
de renforcer la résilience des sociétés
et d'accompagner la transition vers un
modèle de développement soutenable est
conforme à nos objectifs pour le climat
et l'environnement
l'urgence environnementale doit en effet
au coeur de chacun de nos choix d'avenir
sans fatalisme car les experts du giec
nous disent que si nous baissons
rapidement le niveau de nos émissions
nous pouvons encore contenir le
réchauffement à 2 voire même un degré et
demi celsius il est urgent d'agir
mais il n'est pas trop tard
et le faire aussi sans demi mesure car
comme l'a dit avec force au secrétaire
général nous courons aujourd'hui à la
catastrophe en raison d'engagements
insuffisant qui nous mènerait un
réchauffement climatique de 2,7 degrés
dont nous finirions tous sans exception
par payer le prix fort
la coop 26 qui s'ouvrira le 1er novembre
prochain sera donc un moment de vérité
chacun d'entre nous doit en
responsabilité y apporter une
contribution à la mesure des enjeux à
savoir des milliers de vies humaines la
stabilité internationale l'avenir des
nouvelles générations
avant qu'il ne soit trop tard nous
devons nous retrouver autour de
l'objectif de neutralité climatique à
l'horizon 2050 là encore la france sera
solidaire elle apportera 6 milliards
d'euros par an et consacrera plus d'un
tiers de ses financements à l'adaptation
climatique
ce combat pour le climat doit aller de
pair avec le combat pour la biodiversité
à marseille lors du congrès mondial de
nature bio lui scène qui s'est tenu en
début septembre nous avons pris des
engagements forts qu'il nous faut
maintenant mettre en oeuvre en
particulier concrétiser le projet
emblématique de la grande muraille verte
au sel devant aussi mettre en oeuvre la
finance climat au service de la
biodiversité tant les liens entre les
deux sujets sont désormais avérée
dans cette période de redémarrage de
l'économie mondiale nous devons enfin
veiller à ce que nos pratiques
commerciales soient bien compatible avec
notre volonté de solidarité
internationale et nos objectifs
climatiques et environnementaux en nous
donnant de nouveaux leviers conforme
droit de l'om c'est comme le mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières que
nous voulons mettre en place en europe
pour lutter contre les fuites de carbone
de la même manière que nous voulons
lutter contre la déforestation a porté
contre les violations des droits sociaux
tout au long de nos chaînes de valeur et
puis en travaillant dans le même temps
verdissement concret du cadre commercial
multilatéral des la ministérielle omc de
cette année à commencer par un accord
ambitieux pour réguler les subventions à
la pêche il y va du futur de nos océans
nous avons enfin une responsabilité à
l'égard des principes mêmes du
multilatéralisme dont nous sommes les
dépositaires
la responsabilité d'abord de préserver
notre capacité à agir au nom de ses
principes et promouvoir un ordre
international réellement multilatérales
à cet égard monsieur le secrétaire
général je tiens à saluer votre action
et vos efforts pour insuffler une
nouvelle dynamique au système des
nations unies nous serons à vos côtés
tout au long de votre second mandat tout
en soutenant nos institutions
collectives y compris dans leurs efforts
de réforme nous devons aussi continuer à
développer un multilatéralisme deux
projets celui de l'alliance pour le
multilatéralisme que nous avons lancé il
y a deux ans avec mon collègue allemand
et qui a su jouer tout son rôle dès le
début de la crise pandémique ou encore
celui de l'alliance internationale pour
la protection du patrimoine dans les
zones de conflits qui réalise un travail
remarquable en irak en syrie aux mâles y
est aussi en afghanistan en lien avec
l'unesco
nous avons la responsabilité aussi de
défendre ces principes là où il va s'il
en afghanistan où les acquis des 20
dernières années ne peuvent s'effacer
tout particulièrement ce qui concerne
l'accès à l'éducation et les droits des
femmes et des filles est partout où la
portée universelle des droits humains
est remise en cause car l'universalité
de ses droits et la première traduction
politique et juridique de l'unité du
genre humain sur laquelle cette
organisation notre organisation serait
dépourvue de fondement il j également je
le rappelle d'un engagement que les
états membres des nations unies ont
librement consenti à signer et à
respecter ses principes qui nous
rassemble nous avons enfin la
responsabilité de les faire vivre au
présent en les portant jusque dans
l'espace numérique
nous y voyons prospérer des
comportements de plus en plus
irresponsables sont pas venir
malheureusement apporter une réponse
normative international à même de
réguler ces dérives et d'y faire
respecter les droits et les libertés de
tous la mise en place d'un impôt
universel minima bhl de 15% pour les
entreprises multinationales et
contribuera nous appelons donc tous les
états se rallier à cette mesure est
essentielle
la france et ses partenaires européens
entendent même se doter d'une véritable
législation sur les marchés numériques
nous encourageons nos partenaires
internationaux à nous suivre sur cette
voie et nous les invitons à oeuvrer avec
nous à l'instauration d'un nouvel ordre
public numérique dans le sillage de
l'appel de paris ou de l'appel de
christchurch qui depuis 2010 note vous
permet désormais d'agir de manière
décisive pour obtenir le retrait de
contenus terroriste sur internet
responsabilité collective dans le
maintien de la paix et de la sécurité
internationales
responsabilité partagée face aux grands
défis d'aujourd'hui
responsabilité de chacun d'entre nous à
l'égard de ceux là mêmes qui nous
rassemble voilà pour la france ce
qu'appelle le moment de bascule
historique que nous sommes en train de
vivre nous devons tous ept ou rendez
vous
alors que notre pays s'apprête à exercer
la présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne au premier semestre 2022 vous
pouvez mesdames et messieurs compter sur
notre détermination
assumer pleinement notre part de cette
triple responsabilité en nous engageant
dans tous les combats de la sécurité de
la solidarité et de l'égalité pour
rebâtir avec vous notre monde commun je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
je remercie le ministre de laurent peu
des affaires étrangères de la france de
la déclaration qu'il vient de prononcer
je donne maintenant la parole à son
excellence monsieur les jeunes les
limbes et la ministre des affaires
étrangères du cameroun
[Musique]